Hi, this is Dr. Conner's, continuing our series on understanding SNP defects.
SNP defects, again, stand for single nucleotide polymorphisms.
These are polymorphisms, defects in genetic pathways.
Genetic defects, usually epigenetic defects, caused from originally some environmental toxin,
or alteration into that gene that is passed on to further generations.
When this presentation we're going to talk about CBS pathway, we'll get into what that is,
and the importance of hydrogen sulfide.
So that's what hydrogen sulfide looks like, for you chemists out there.
And before we get into this, we need to go over some general rules with genetic testing.
So if you've seen any of my presentations, I will list this on every single one.
So when we're looking at genetic testing and testing for SNP defects, it's super important
to follow these general rules.
Number one, you do not treat the SNP defect, so you're not treating the defect per se.
You treat other factors of why it's there.
You have to look at the whole person, you have to dig into the cause.
Now, this presentation we're not going to get too much into that, because this presentation
is the importance of hydrogen sulfide and why that is important in your body.
However, you have to look at the cause because a person could have a stip defect
and live to 120 years old, and it never affects them.
But they have a stip defect, and then you add Lyme disease, or H. Pylori, or a bold toxicity,
or heavy metal toxicity, or nervous about a stress, or et cetera, et cetera.
And then that really throws the big picture off for that person.
And it's not a matter of treating the SNP, it's a matter of getting rid of the Lyme.
So even my Lyme patients really struggle with, well, you know, we did the testy done,
we found the defects, why am I not getting better faster?
If you don't kill the Lyme, you're never going to get better.
It's not about treating the SNP, but you have to know that so you could support that.
You also look upstream and downstream, and I show you the next slide of the chart,
you're going to understand that it's a huge complex pattern, and it's all about balance.
So we don't want too much of anything.
It's just like my rule for nutrition.
Too much of a good thing is a bad thing.
It's about balance.
So don't make the American mistake of what vitamin C is good for you.
So I'm going to take 10 that will be really good for me.
It's never that way, and it's not that way when you're looking at genetic testing also.
Number four, we never use protocols.
So that's my rule.
We don't use protocols.
We create a protocol based upon that patient.
We create a protocol around that patient, but we get patients calling all the time.
I have a MTHFR defect.
What should I take?
What's your protocol?
There isn't one.
You have to treat the patient.
And then even at that, you're constantly tweaking, constantly tweaking.
That's just the way it is.
So this is what we're talking about upstream and downstream.
You do not treat the SNP.
You have to treat the whole person, and then it only then can you really support the pathway.
All right, so that makes sense.
I haven't heard that home enough.
So we're looking at a metabolic picture of SNP defects.
There's multiple tests out there.
This right here is a doctor's data test that we use quite frequently.
And the SNP that we're looking at when we're looking at CBS pathway and hydrogen sulfide
is this one right here.
So this is the CBS SNP's that we take a look at.
And when you look at a big pathway planner, thanks to Dr. Ben Lynch of SeekingHealth.org.
There's a bunch of information on his blog, his website, there, too.
He's a fantastic guy.
This, where my arrow is, and what we're looking at when we're talking about the CBS pathway.
And this is just a little snippet of that whole pathway.
It's fed off of the methylation pathway of the methionate pathway,
and the CBS is the start of the transulfiration pathway.
They all fit together in a beautiful giant jigsaw puzzle
that if you're missing one piece, it can really throw off the big picture.
But you have to look at the big picture.
Now, the CBS pathway feeds from this methionate pathway.
The CBS pathway is the only way that your body could get rid of homocysteine.
So what are the indications that there's a blockage in the CBS pathway?
Is on a standard blood test, the person has high homocysteine levels.
So if the person has high homocysteine levels, it's a pretty good chance.
They're not pushing down through that CBS pathway and getting rid of homocysteine.
Now, there could be other issues, too, but that's a pretty good indication.
This presentation is about the importance of hydrogen sulfide.
So we're looking at it in this pathway.
Now, this is a big picture here.
What was circled in the previous pathway is still circled in this pathway.
And the arrow is pointed to CBS because I know it's really hard to see this on this slide.
And then that feeds down to this big circle on the bottom, which creates glutathione,
which feeds it into the crebs cycle, which gets rid of hydrogen peroxide in your body,
gets rid of free radicals, radical oxygen species, et cetera, et cetera.
It's so important as kind of an antioxidant detoxification pathway, energy-making pathway,
your crebs cycle makes all your ATP, et cetera.
So it's really, really important.
And you don't want too much and you don't want too little.
So now that being said as a precursor, why is hydrogen sulfide so important?
Because I read that hydrogen sulfide is not good for you.
Better fact, in work environments that they're producing hydrogen sulfide gas,
it's very toxic and can kill you.
So that's very true.
But we're talking about the hydrogen sulfide that's made intracellularly.
Intercellular hydrogen sulfide makes, it does very important things in your body.
It's a powerful antioxidant.
It itself feeds the increase of glutathione production.
And we're going to have a whole presentation of glutathione, so I'll leave that alone.
It scavenges.
It goes and gombles up superoxide ions that are so damaging, it causes cell death and cell issues.
Hydrogen peroxide that's very damaging to cells.
And peroxidite trait, which is extremely damaging to cells.
So it's a great antioxidant and needed incorrect concentrations.
Now, remember, if you watched any of my videos on cancer,
we always want antioxidants and anti-inflammatories, et cetera, right?
However, remember that there is a balance even in this.
There's a balance.
You need oxidants.
You need pro-inflammatory cytokines and chemicals in your body.
Those are the things that kill bacteria, kill mold, kill lime.
But when it's out of balance, it starts killing your old cells and we have an issue.
So it's all about balance.
Everything in your body is about balance.
So don't watch a presentation like this.
It's going to go all great.
I want to increase my hydrogen sulfide level.
So I'm going to do this and this and this.
Because I want to really super-increase my hydrogen sulfide levels.
It's the wrong way to look at anything.
Hydrogen sulfide also inhibits reactive oxygen species caused by hypoxia,
which is very important for cancer patients.
So there's multiple studies that show the hypoxia around cancer increases
reactive oxygen species.
And that can actually damage your old white blood cell attack on the cancer.
So if a person has a CBS pathway blockage and therefore is decreasing production
of hydrogen sulfide and glutathione, they are also increasing the ability
for a cancer growth to grow unabated.
So we want to look at these pathways with cancer patients too because we may want
to support that pathway with different nutrients that will help push that pathway and to help
decrease reactive oxygen species that are produced by a cancer.
It also inhibits cox-mediated inflammation.
So pro-inflammatory cytokines due to chronic infection, et cetera,
can have just huge damaging effects on a person.
And that's what can lead to cancer again.
So my specialty is cancer.
This is a big important factor in how we look at patients.
When you have chronic inflammation in the body causes all sorts of problems and it can lead
to cancer.
NF-caphabata also is a source of chronic inflammation, it's an inflammatory barker as well.
So are these cytokines that don't regulate IL-6, IL-8 and IL-1B.
So here the bottom is a picture of NF-caphabata and the issues that it creates in your body.
What interested study talked about NF-caphabata decreasing the ability for tumor to
grow this factor to cause apoptosis in a cancer cell.
So remember apoptosis is the program cell death that is not taking place in a person with
cancer.
So that cancer cell is not dying and it's in a state of rapid replication.
Well, one of the reasons that's that that is happening is an up-regulation of nuclear
factor-caphabata.
So NF-caphabata is up-regulated in cancer and it's not clear that if it was up-regulated
therefore it is a cause of cancer or is it up-regulated by the cancer cell itself, regardless
it itself protects against that cancer cell's death.
So as your immune system is attempting to kill a cancer cell, the up-regulation, the increase
in nuclear factor-caphabata in a cancer cell blocks apoptosis.
So it keeps it from undergoing death.
So it actually inhibits chemotherapy and inhibits chemotherapy is trying to increase apoptosis.
So it inhibits the natural cell death of the cancer cell and keeps that cancer cell alive
not good.
So we want to do things that will decrease these inflammatory markers like NF-caphabata
and the Cox-mediated inflammation and will help increase your ability to go through apoptosis.
So again, this is a nice diagram of methionine which was way up high on that other chart that
I showed you.
It goes to herbocystine, herbocystine that goes through the CBS cycle, that's what's called
trans-alpheration and all sorts of good things take place.
If there's a blockage and you have a hyper- herbocystidemia, which means you have an increased
herbocystine, all sorts of bad things take place.
Remember, it's all about balance.
It's all about balance in every one of these co-factors and every one of these pathways.
So it's not about just pushing one thing.
It's about keeping a balance because get out of balance and everything, anything in life
and we can have issues.
So this is another little snippet of that pathway.
The CBS edzyme gene creates hydrogen sulfide in several places on the arrows on the right
of this and another little snippet.
This is what we're talking about.
Homocystine goes through CBS to form hydrogen sulfide, goes down through those other pathways
to form all those other things that will hit on further presentations.
But just in this presentation, one of the hit number one, it's all about balance, number
two.
When we're dealing with cancer or chronic inflammation of any kind which is a chronic infection which
could be Lyme disease, which could be H. Pylori, which could be any type of chronic subclinical
infection that the person doesn't even know that they have.
This is why H. Pylori and such are causative factors of cancer.
We're going to have a down-regulated CBS pathway.
So if we can help support the up-regulation, if we can increase this pathway, increase hydrogen
sulfide.
And later we'll talk about glutathione and this is exactly why a person with a down-regulated
CBS pathway has less energy because they're not producing ATP, we'll get into that as well.
But it helps us understand why things are taking place and where we really want to support
different metabolic pathways and how it can really help people with cancer, chronic Lyme,
chronic fatigue, chronic disorders of multiple kinds.
So I hope this helps.
I know I speak really fast.
I'm going to apologize.
Listen to this again.
Hopefully it's not too technical, but I've tried to simplify something that can be sometimes
kind of confusing.
All right.
Talk to you soon.